ja also mein thema ist heute die
spaltung in der gesellschaft
und wir haben das jetzt nicht hier so
richtig erlebt habe man merkt dass
corona ein sehr aufgeheiztes thema ist
und das ist eine zu einer großen
spaltung vor allen dingen in der frage
kämpften um geimpften welche rolle
spielen die umkämpften an der pandemie
es sind die dafür schuld daran schuld
dass ist dass es die diese hohe
effizienzen gibt zum beispiel und ein
ein thema was sich besonders ansprechen
möchte ist in diesem kontext die
nebenwirkungen weil es gibt eine sehr
aufgeheizte diskussion gerade was die
nebenwirkungen angeht die eine seite
sagt nebenwirkung fast jeder kriegt
nebenwirkung schwere nebenwirkungen
viele werden langfristig daran große
probleme bekommen die andere seite augen
sagt das gibt es nicht zb
paul-ehrlich-institut wenn wir die
todeszahlen anguckt da haben wir
inzwischen 22 1000 verdachts-
todesmeldungen zusammen mit der impfung
ungefähr und das paul ehrlich institut
sagt davon sind ungefähr 80 gibt es
einen kausalen zusammenhang und die
anderen
1900 sind es statistische effekte so was
ist die wahrheit das wissen verlegt die
wahrheit wird vielleicht wie immer in
solchen sachen irgendwo in der mitte
liegen und die frage ist wie er verfasst
man das und weil diese impfstoffe neu
sind weil sie sehr schnell entwickelt
worden sind die testung sehr schnell
gelaufen ist müsste man im prinzip jetzt
wo viele leute sich haben impfen lassen
im guten glauben müsste man eines eine
eine richtige erfassung machen dass man
die diese dieser nebenwirkung
systematisch erfasst in einer so
genannten kohortenstudie oder was
ähnliches das hat das wollte man bei
kurve den anfang machen es leider nicht
gemacht worden aber wir dürfen das kein
zweites mal verpassen dass wir eine
solche kohortenstudie dass wir eine
systematische und lückenlose erfassung
der nebenwirkung auch über die jahre
hinweg jetzt bekommen und ich arbeite
mit anderen wissenschaftlern zusammen da
initiative dass wir so was auf die beine
stellen es wäre auch natürlich super
das paul-ehrlich-institut zum beispiel
eine solche initiative unterstützen
würde und vielleicht einerseits die
gruppe die sich haben impfen lassen zu
beruhigen dass es diese nebenwirkungen
doch nicht gibt in der frequenz oder auf
der anderen seite wenn es dann
tatsächlich wäre neben mir gibt das die
identifiziert werden auf dauer und da
glaube ich ist eine lücke die wir jetzt
schließen müssen herr professor sie
haben ja gleich zwei themenkomplexe
angesprochen einmal die kohorte die
spaltung der gesellschaft ganz gerne
einfach zunächst einmal auf das erste
tier spaltung der gesellschaft ja
antworten und bin nicht ihrer meinung
und trotzdem sind wir beide nicht und
muss hier keine risse in syrien kommen
also die spaltung befindet in dem fall
nicht statt weil wir uns ja schätzen und
einfach ganz normal miteinander umgehen
obwohl wir am main und das ist glaube
dann auch ganz wichtig genau und wenn
man und da würd ich ihnen widersprechen
sich zahlen anschaut von umfragen
bertelsmann beispielsweise aber auch
konrad an herr richtung dann kommen die
umfragen eigentlich einem anderen
ergebnis die kommt er zum ergebnis dass
die zahl der menschen die sagen in
diesem land stehen wir unversöhnlich
gegenüber eher geschrumpft ist okay gut
ja einer gefahr ist also beispielsweise
die akkuraten ausstellung der wert von
4,1 prozent ist gesungen auf einen 3
prozent jetzt aktuell ja es heißt
offenbar ist damit unserer wahrnehmung
etwas nicht ganz richtig wenn wir von
spaltungen sprechen vielleicht haben wir
deutschen auch zu lange in so einer
angesagten haase alle gelebt haben man
muss gar nicht mehr streiten müssen ja
wir machen so ein bisschen näher und
sind alle happy und jetzt plötzlich
schnell wieder fest mensch es gibt ein
thema was uns total emotionalisiert und
wir sind einfach mal anderer meinung
aber sie sind sie so uns deswegen
natürlich nicht irgendwie mit hass und
hetze ja das ist richtig aber sind
anderer meinung sie hat ihren weg auch
ein bisschen härter aber tauschen
einfach mal meinungen aus gerade die
waren thema im pflicht ja aber jetzt
also ist es ist tatsächlich so ich da
gibt es ein widerspruch auf der einen
seite gibt es viele leute die das
persönlich nicht erleben aber ich denke
gerade einen artikel nicht gelesen haben
im fokus die letzten tage wo
es ging mein patient der nicht geimpft
hat einen schwereren verlauf hatte im
krankenhaus und dann hat man ihnen die
schuld gegeben für diesen verlauf der
habe ich nicht bedankt und dann gab es
viele kommentare unter diesem artikel
nicht geimpfte menschen die sonnen
höheren krankenkassenbeitrag wie soll
man nicht auf die intensivstation und
ich glaube das problem ist dass es in
der gesellschaft wahrscheinlich nicht so
präsent ist aber es gibt immer wieder in
den medien
versuche eine solche spaltung zu treiben
und ich glaube so kommen wir nicht
weiter wir müssen eigentlich an der
frage ob jemand der
höhere kosten verursachen dass man sich
jetzt ganz unabhängig aber jemand der
höhere kosten verursacht also ein
autofahrer beispielsweise der jeden
zweiten tag ein unfall macht der muss
natürlich eine höhere
versicherungsprämie bezahl jahre ist
doch per se erst mal nichts zu sagen
deswegen wenn man diesen vorschlag
machen würde kann man darüber dass gute
nein das wird ja das leitung nichts zu
tun na ja das würde ich nicht so sehen
also der der arzt oder der dass das
medizinisch system aber der arzt hat
seine patienten immer zu behandeln
unabhängig davon ob er jetzt an dieser
erkrankung an der ursache der erkrankung
beteiligt das was ist mit menschen die
rauchen mit übergewicht menschen
menschen mit diabetes man muss jeden
menschen gleich behandeln völlig
unabhängig was seine herkunft ist was
über schuld hatte diese schuldfrage
dürfen wir uns gar nicht stellen weil
wenn wir das anfangen zu stellen wo
hören wir damit auf und das ist glaube
ich schon ein schwieriges problem wie
hol mal eben das oft klaus rein ich
wollte was ganz am anfang waren zum
thema spaltung der gesellschaft und fand
ganz interessant auch was sie gesagt
haben schäfer das einerseits ja die
gesellschaft sogar zusammengeführt wurde
durch corona bei einigen fragen aber was
wird trotzdem aussehen müssen da gab es
zum beispiel vor einigen monaten eine
ganz spannende 1 bach umfrage hat das
verstanden dass immer mehr menschen in
deutschland sagen ja es gibt
meinungsfreiheit aber man kann nicht
mehr alles aussprechen weil man
befürchten muss man wird sozial
stigmatisiert in irgendeiner ecke
gestellt wenn man zum beispiel
irgendwelche ängste äußert
in dem das thema migration da gibt es
einiges an dieser naja ich weiß nicht
was passiert dann wird das gerne
ansprechen ohne dass das jetzt nazis
sind und den wird immer gleich was
unterstellt und das ist brandgefährlich
für eine gesellschaft weil die menschen
dann was unterdrücken nicht mehr auf
freisprechen und am ende sich das häufig
auch in den wahlkabinen entlädt und wir
so was ja in anderen ländern auch
gesehen großbritannien haben wir ganz am
anfang erwähnt aber vor allem auch die
usa da gibt es ja diese sogenannte
wagnis bewegung wir kommen ja nachher
glaube ich auch noch mal darauf zu
sprechen und immer mehr personen die
sagen ja die menschen sollen gewisse
gruppen einsortiert werden es gibt
vorgaben was man vielleicht noch sagen
davon denken darf und dass sorgt am ende
dafür dass der unmut in der gesellschaft
wächst das frust wächst und dass sich
das irgendwann entlädt und im
schlimmsten fall den populisten am
linken und rechten rand entstehen und
das müssen wir in deutschland verändern
deswegen muss diese studie von 1 bach
wirklich alle in der politik und in der
gesellschaft noch unter 50 prozent der
deutschen die hand haben genau wir
hatten eine wenn ich sie richtig im kopf
wir hatten zumal 60er 70er jahre maniche
6 prozent der deutschen die gesagt
hatten ja man kann nicht immer alles
aussprechen also eine sehr geringe zahl
um mittlerweile sind wir laut allensbach
bei über 50 prozent es ist seit 1953 der
schlechteste wert da muss man dazu
aussagen die studie
sehr gerne weil ich gerne das ist
wirklich die spaltung ist schon so auch
zeigt bei viktor hier war schon der
perfekte bei zu dir übergeworfen die ist
denn so in england in großbritannien wie
würdest du da die spaltung einschätzen
was dort studiert sie ist nicht so groß
wie in deutschland denn das problem in
deutschland sind auch zum teil die
medien ich darf noch erinnern an diese
silvesternacht als zehn tage lang keiner
wusste was passiert war denn es gab
keine informationen und die medien
hatten sich sozusagen so eine mauer des
schweigens aufgebaut und haben nicht
kommuniziert darüber was da wirklich
passiert ist und sie haben es vorhin
angesprochen migrationshintergrund in
köln oder ja genau 49 genau die java
problem hat gilt hat schon am zweiten
tag
darüber sehr glücklich den fall
berichtet wird hat berichtet aber die
meisten leute wussten tagelang nicht die
leute die nicht bei diesen wussten nicht
was passiert war und dann als es dann
aufgaben hatten sie das gefühl aha wir
wurden hier tagelang im dunkeln gelassen
und das macht was mit der
meinungsfreiheit das macht das damit
dass man nicht mehr das gefühl hat dass
ehrlich mit einem umgegangen wird ich
weiß was du etwas meint sich war in
london kürzlichen da hat eine
engländerin zu werke eine deutsche die
in england lebt hat sie gesagt warum
verbreitete medien eigentlich so eine
panik meine eltern die haben wirklich
richtig angst und ich sage immer in
england gab es von anfang an
unterschiedliche standpunkte wie würden
sie das denn einschätzen hat das
vielleicht was damit zu tun dass man
vielleicht auch gefühlt die spaltung der
gesellschaft mehr für ihn eigentlich
glaube schon dass es dass es eine
spaltung gibt und ich glaube ich bin
nicht nicht ganz ihrer meinung ich
glaube schon dass an dieser corona frage
wie gerade mit den ungeimpften
umgegangen wurde wie sie wie das
thematisiert wurde in den medien ja ich
habe diesen focus artikel vorhin erwähnt
ist wirklich unfair und ungerecht weil
es ist ja so dass sie diese eine impfung
jede medizinische jeden fall jeder
medizinische intervention setzt die
einwilligung des patienten voraus ich
darf den patienten nicht behandelter
patient nicht das nicht will auch wenn
es jetzt zu seinem guten wenn seine eine
richtige behandlung ist er braucht und
er möchte die behandlung nicht haben
dann darf ich nicht behandeln sonst
einer körperverletzung und das ist ein
ganz wichtiges prinzip in der medizin
und wir wir es haben uns ein stück weit
doch darüber hinweggesetzt und dann
haben wir auch noch die die personen die
sich dann aus welchem grund auch immer
gegen eine impfung entschieden haben
doch ein stück weit stigmatisiert und
das sehe ich schon als problem okay sie
reden jetzt über die spaltung der
gesellschaft die wir vorgenommen haben
weil wir zwischen geimpften gmbh an ok
entschuldigung das habe ich
doch alle wenig
ich würde ihnen um den austausch des
nano oder
ganz wichtig vielleicht zu unterscheiden
also es kann ja sein das haben sie im
jahr auch gesagt dass man sagt es gibt
vielleicht die eine hälfte dieser so im
land und die andere hälfte sieht es
anders sagen wir in großbritannien
erlebt bei der bread abstimmung war fast
50 50 wenn das aber auf augenhöhe
diskussion gibt und man sagt man
akzeptiert auch die meinung des anderen
wir stimmen dann irgendwann ab und
akzeptieren das ergebnis muss das ja
nicht für eine gespaltene gesellschaft
rächen im gegenteil das kann sogar eine
demokratische gesellschaft auszeichnen
sind wie man so einen dvi oder wir sind
mittlerweile wieder sehr sehr einig
sie sind wir weit entfernt aber dass das
ist wichtig und dann kann es auch eine
gesellschaft kann aber auch gespalten
seien man sagt 80 prozent versuchen 20
prozent zu unterdrücken oder die
auszugrenzen dann war
ein lehrstück der demokratie denn die
hälfte kann man kann man zusehen ja wenn
man sagt alle akzeptieren es danach und
das war aus meiner sicht so dass
wirklich sehr viele gesagt haben okay
jetzt abgestimmt worden deswegen muss
das nicht für eine spaltung sprechen
völlig richtig und worum es mir ja eben
gegen war dass man viele den eindruck
haben sie können nicht mehr alles
aussprechen können nicht mehr alle
ängste artikulieren und das ist auf
dauer sehr schlecht für eine demokratie
und das sehen wir vor allem in den usa
auch wohin das führt und gibt ja viele
weitere beispiele dass einige sage ich
trau mich vielleicht gar nicht mehr zu
sagen
eskimo indianer oder wörter die
eigentlich zu unserem sprachgebrauch ist
doch schon so lange muss ich eher einen
gefallen ganz gut stellen ich habe schon
das gefühl gehabt in letzten jahren dass
jemand der sich gegen die impfung
entschieden ist nicht gerne gemacht hat
und auch hier in den runden muss ich
auch nicht haben wir immer betont wir
sehen das so aber ich bin dreifach
geimpft und hab den booster auch schon
es hat man wirklich immer dazu gesagt
aus angst vor kritik ich habe das auch
gemacht ich habe immer meinen status
betont das mache ich jetzt übrigens
nicht mehr sie mich eine persönliche
entscheidung werde ist nicht mehr da
bist du dreimal
wurde allerdings schon öffentlich hier
mehr festigkeit der bögen den ich meine
das ist eigentlich eine für mich ist es
eine total persönliche entscheidung ist
man hat ja auch nicht früher ich hab
doch nicht früher wenn wir uns erst mal
begegnet sind ein impfausweis rausgeholt
in der zeitung sagt zach mal wisse
dagegen wer sich alles geld wenn und ist
das nicht ein problem geworden finde ich
also das ist er also nach es ist diese
moralische überladung einer
medizinischen frage und das und diese
schuld da kommt diesen schuld aspekt
rein und er gehört überhaupt nicht in
die medizin reihen sie sich dass man
eine schuld basierte sicht auf medizin
da müssen das müssen wir wirklich
vermeiden ja er hat sie alle
krankenversicherung funktionieren
bisschen anders wissen sie wenn ich
dauernd zum arzt gehe habe ich einen
deutlich höheren beitrag dann da wird
schon geguckt welches risiko hab ich
also die private krankenversicherung
arbeitet natürlich und das ist glaube
ich vollkommen richtig mit einem anreiz
mechanismus und sagt wenn du der meinung
bist du musst was ganz gefährliches
machen die ganze zeit dann verursachte
höhere kosten und warum soll die
allgemeinheit dafür bezahlen wenn du
privat sagt ich will aber an aber wenn
ich ein gleich sind unglaublich ganz gut
aber wenn der skifahrer zum dritten mal
in der in der notaufnahme auftaucht mit
seinem beinbruch darf der arzt nicht
sagen oder böse ski fahre ich habe
eigentlich nicht ein sondern mussten
genauso vorsichtig das ist ja hier auch
nicht passiert also da muss man ich
glaube es gibt nur einen unterschied bei
der debatte da will ich mal hier alleine
in der runde gegen alle argumentieren
beim nächsten thema ankommen dann beim
nächsten mal dann bei der einstellung
ganz schnell bei den skifahrern haben
wir nie die diskussion gibt es wegen zu
vieler skifahrer eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems die hatten wir bei
vor ein paar monaten mit blick auf zu
viele ungeimpfte und haben natürlich
viele geimpfte gesagt wir können jetzt
nicht wochenlang in ein locker umgehen
mit einschränkungen leben und
möglicherweise droht eine überlastung
des gesamten fußball hydro der center
kam ein neues bretton ja machen deswegen
ist das ist das schon anders gelagert
bei der diskussion um im geimpft und
nicht geimpfte und auf der anderen seite
skifahrer oder hier aber wenn man nur
vier prozent der intensivbetten 2020
waren mit krone patienten belegt 96
prozent in der siebten waren nicht mehr
aufmachen aber noch erwähnen die
recherche von tim röhn das ist ein welt
kollege der ja viel aber intensiv
recherchiert